we've been looking at matrices right and
so far what we did is we compared them
to what you already know and we looked
at processes for how to solve systems of
linear equations do you have that
systems of linear equations okay now we
said you can use a matrix right an
Augmented matrix to solve the system of
linear equations in exactly the same way
that you're used to working with
simultaneous equations but we should use
this idea of row operations right how
you can manipulate entire equations at a
time sometimes a whole bunch of them
okay so this is kind of something you
already knew how to do taking a new tool
and apply it to an existing problem what
we're going to start doing now is see
how the new tool can let you view it
more complicated new problems okay
so we're moving away from the older
stuff so to begin with rather than give
you all the theory and the processes and
the algorithms for do dealing with what
you've got in front of you I'm gonna
give you an analogy it's about sushi so
I think it was subheading for you okay
now I'm interested in calculating my
sushi profits okay that's really that's
really what this is about I think sir
that's just suppose I know the school
Cantina sells a few different kinds of
sushi let's some push it up a little
upmarket right ah three different kinds
just for the sake of simplicity I'm
gonna make there let's see like you know
teriyaki chicken or something like that
yo
which is which is my personal favorite
and I think I think we're up mocking
enough to self-heal and ask for Katy and
then uh might be a cheap owner so do you
like something vegetarian would be the
cheaper okay so
three forms of sushi and of course
because they've all got different greens
they cost different about okay so I
think you know sort of a standard price
might be like three bucks for your more
classy one eels more expensive you might
have to pay an extra dollar for that one
and if there's no protein in it okay
we'll give you that one for a little
cheaper okay sit now they have surprises
now to work out what my profits are
right or maybe I should just say total
sales I want to know how much I sell
let's just say over a week okay just
over a week so if I had for myself some
Monday information Tuesday Wednesday and
so on okay if I knew how much I saw on
each day of each of the kinds of sushi
right then I could work out what my
total sales but then for what my profits
going to be okay so I guess I need to
know not just for each day but I need to
know like the individual ones so I'm
gonna have my my chicken here eel and my
avocado ones here right now so that we
actually can work with this and get some
concrete numbers I've made up some data
okay so not only ever got these prices
but let me show you how much we've sold
each day okay so here we go icky some
information
so I have to be walking they go okay so
here we go I've got some data now and I
can work this out
what would be a nice logical way to go
about this okay so I'm gonna make a new
sort of space scenario how would you go
about calculating if you want to like
say set up a spreadsheet to do this for
yourself and you are gonna use a
calculator even though that I was a
relatively small how would you do this
in a logical way okay well I would
suggest maybe we go through day by day I
think that's a normal way to go about it
so let's say sales for Monday okay how
much are you going to work out as your
total of mouth okay now I'm gonna do a
bit something a bit unusual rather than
write my first line of working yeah I'm
gonna ask you to leave that first line
of working empty first second we got to
feel something in there in a few minutes
okay let's just start on the second line
how would you work out your bottom line
for Monday not not a trick question what
would you do
good okay so what we're going to do is
in case you didn't catch that right
we're gonna match up these quantities
with these prices that makes sense right
and then you want to play through you
should be able to total okay so we gonna
do two things are going to multiply it
and then we're gonna add let's just
write that down
I'll go from the top so 13 times 3
they'll give you your chicken sales 8
times 4 that'll give you put your sales
and then lastly 6 times 2 okay these
numbers are small enough we can deal
with this right
39:32 12 let's see 39 plus 1250 1 plus
theta 2 that should give you 83 dollars
you okay with that so far so good
okay now this process gave the sales for
one day is exactly the same for all the
other days right so can I give you like
maybe a minute or so let's let's we've
got four left to go okay this is come
over here you guys do Tuesday you guys
work out the Tuesday some this can you
work out Wednesday Thursday and Friday
you do that quickly and then hand me
your numbers when you're done
okay that's not time there's just a
simple calculation so let's get some
numbers out Shh
what do we got here Tuesday total 63
where 63 yep cool all right
Wednesday 37 next day 75 good and end of
the week what do you have for Friday
what do you want yeah there's a bit of
slow day wasn't it okay good so let's
have a look at what we've done this
operation that we've done right I wish
to notice a couple things
it received it took in turn tables of
values can you see that
right he's table number one right here's
table number two and what output was a
third table okay does that make sense
so what should have done is actually
take two matrices that's all tables are
right you've taken two matrices and you
have done a kind of multiplication to
them right it's kind of taking
everything I think getting the sums over
all right so how would we write this in
matrix notation keys the way we're doing
okay
what you've done is excuse me he's your
first matrix okay so you've got three
quantities and writing it like that okay
they represent three different variables
there okay and then you've multiplied by
and now he's your set of data down here
okay
so he's that table
okay now what was the result that we got
this was our result down here right
oops that's a bit close together but you
get you okay so we need to put a name on
this because as you can see right like
this process that we've walked through
in some senses it was arbitrary like why
don't we add the pigs up why not like
say take a difference or why did we why
did we multiply down this way and not
cost that way in substances it was
arbitrary so this is really one kind of
multiplication and there are lots of
different kinds of multiplication so
presses this one here and it's led after
the symbol this is called cross
multiplication you're like what other
kind of multiplication is there and the
answer is well you've already done one
it's this kind up here this is a
different kind of multiplication right
again you were taking two matrices right
even in the first case up here from
Monday
you took this matrix and you took this
matrix like this two matrices but when
you multiply them you just got a number
at the end okay so we want to
distinguish between these two some kinds
of multiplication you just get a number
other kinds of multiplication you end up
with another matrix after you write so
how do we write these in different ways
well this one up here and this is what
you can put in that line okay and this
was not babysit so these you already
know we want another symbol for
multiplication you guys already know
another signal for multiplication it's a
dot
okay like so so again I was multiplying
she eventually I suppose I could put
that vertical it doesn't really matter
this up here is called don't want
revision or a dot product and they're
different okay because what you've ended
up with at the end is just a number
right do you remember I told you a bit
of a funny word for this it started with
an S a couple lessons ago right when
you've got things that have just numbers
they're black matrices we call them yep
scalar very good so this is called a
scalar product or a dot product okay
whereas this is called a cross product
or if you want to get more technical but
I'm not going to go into the details of
why at the moment it's also sometimes
called a vector oops a victor pride okay
but where you're not going to get into
vectors it's a it's a big can of worms
even though it's really cool with it at
the time for it at the moment so this is
how you multiply matrices together
first you work out these dot products
these scalar parts and in this case
there were five of them and then you put
them together and you get a bit ryx